and we are constantly working to ensure
that let's break out of uh that
commercial break and listen to Oliver
down and making a statement on so as
part of that effort I recently
commissioned a review by our cyber
Security Experts to assess the risks
posed by certain third-party apps on
government devices
and in particular the installation and
use of tick tock now I know Mr Deputy
speaker that there has been a lot of
interest in this in the house I wanted
to take the opportunity today to update
members that review has now concluded
and it is clear that there could be a
risk around how sensitive government
data is accessed and used by certain
platforms
as many colleagues will know social
media apps collect and store huge
amounts of user data including contacts
user content and geolocation data
on government devices that data can be
sensitive and so today we are
strengthening the security of those
devices in two key respects
first we are moving to a system where
government devices will only be able to
access third-party apps that are on a
pre-approved list
this system is already in place across
many departments now it will be the rule
across government
second we are also going to ban the use
of tick tock on government devices
we will do so with immediate effect
Mr Speaker this is a precautionary move
we know that there is already limited
use of tick tock across government but
it is also good cyber hygiene
given the particular risk around
government devices which may contain
sensitive information it is both prudent
and proportionate to restrict the use of
certain apps particularly when it comes
to apps where a large amount of data can
be stored and accessed
span applies to government corporate
devices within ministerial and
non-ministerial departments but it will
not extend to personal devices for
government employees or ministers or the
general public that is because as I have
outlined this is a proportionate move
based on a specific risk with government
devices however as is always the case we
do advise individuals to practice
caution online and to consider each
social media platform's data policies
before downloading and using them and of
course it is the case that ministers
receive regular security briefings and
advice on protecting data on their
personal devices and on mitigating cyber
threats
we will also be putting in place
specific very limited exemptions for the
use of tick tock on government devices
where it is required for operational
reasons those exemptions will only be
granted by security teams on a
case-by-case basis with ministerial
clearance provided as appropriate
overall this approach aligns with action
taken by allies including the United
States Canada and the EU
Mr Speaker Mr Deputy speaker our
security must always come first and
today we are strengthening that security
in a prudent and proportionate way and I
commend this statement to the house